I thought that we could talk about
fractions so far as us 1 over 2 also
known as 1/2 okay so another one will be
2 over 5 or 2/5 and then there are more
complicated ones like 18 over 42 and
well you know there is something a
little wrong here which is that the top
and the bottom you can both divide them
by 2 and then you get that this is 9
over 21 and oh I'm not done
and so it's 3/7 I wanted to do this
example because all the fractions are
going to consider they're going to be
reduced like this namely it's going to
be on the form P over Q where P and Q
are integers and they are what we call
Kapena namely that they have no common
divisor we cancel them down as far as I
can go
that's completely correct yes and now if
you remember with fractions you can do
things you can add them up or you can
multiply them and multiplication is
fairly easy because if I want to take 4
is 2 over 5 2/5 and I want to boot apply
it with 3 over 7 I take the two numbers
at the top I will apply them and I take
the two numbers idle bar and I multiply
them and so they give me 6 over 35
that's pretty simple
however I don't know if you remember
this but if you want to add them I'm
going to tell you what it is not equal
to I have to put a big knot like this so
it is not 2 plus 3 / 5 + 7 5 over 12 I
hope you remember that you're not
supposed to do that
and so let me remind you of what you are
supposed to do you're going to reduce
them to a common denominator which in
this case
we'll be five times seven I just want to
remind you of what people told you you
should always do but we could ask
ourselves what if we decide that this
was the correct rule and break the rules
away we're going to break the rules yes
I'm going to venture in the brand new
world because I don't want to go against
the other people we're going to create a
new edition and to remember it's new
this plus I'm going to put a circle
around it five over twelve it's a symbol
that we mathematicians we use a lot
every time we mean well it's not quite
what you think it is we could put a hat
on top we do things like that or tilde
okay and so let me do it with letters
like this P and Q that will means that P
over Q funny addition P primer over Q PI
mine is P plus P prime divided by Q plus
Q pine probably you never heard of it
but it's actually when known among
mathematicians and it has a name that's
cold so I mean like the fabric addition
named after John five who was mostly
known as a geologist in the end of the
18th century my intention is to show you
that this funny addition actually comes
up in two very different contexts the
original one discovered by five and
another one which will be called the
four circles what we're going to do is
that we're going to list all possible
fractions there are a lot of numbers so
we're going to only to focus on the ones
between zero and one that's going to
shrink and so here is the number line
I'm going to be between 0 and 1 and by
the way one is a fraction it's 1 / 1 0
is also functional easy over there is
1/2 1/4 3/4 and then there is one third
which is probably somewhere like here
2/3 somewhere like this in of course
well I can keep going for a long time
because there are infinitely many
numbers so what I'm going to do is that
I'm going to stop and I'm going to take
the numbers PQ so first of all between 0
into 0 & 1 and then we r cubed well I
cannot go anything really so I'm going
to assume Q is going to be less than a
certain number so I let's say 234 this
is there is nothing special about 234 is
just 2 3 4 and that's I don't have much
imagination when picking numbers and so
I'm going to do it and I started doing
it and there are quite a few numbers
like that and so only between 20 and 40
thousand so perhaps I'm not going to do
it in front of you I have a computer and
so I did it and that's not 20,000
fractions I only got a little piece of
it because when I use my computer
I got pages and pages and pages and
pages and so I get all these numbers
between 119 over 81 and 103 over 154 if
you think about it it's about 2/3 so 1
is just little below and one is a little
after and actually there should be 2/3
somewhere I guess here so that it's a
very small piece of the whole list so we
get all the numbers in that very small
interval and they are in order they come
up in this order exactly and so that
looks like that doesn't seem to be any
thing special about this list
right you remember that funny edition
where you add up the two numbers at the
top and the two button you see it here
look for answers you take these three
numbers here look at the one in the
middle
148 whether looks exactly the psalm of
123 and of 25 and then 225 that's
exactly the sum of 187 and 38 and you
see that in many many places so let's
see if we can find another one like that
okay look and read these three I mean
103 plus thirty five hundred and
thirty-eight hundred and fifty-six plus
53 209 31 plus 95 that's hundred 2647
444 191 then it's pretty clear about
there are examples where this is not one
of those fari edition like you have the
ones where in the middle term is not way
way smaller look at this one here and if
I take the sum of the two the five a sum
of the two on the edges so that gives me
two hundred and twelve divided by 320
and all the paper is 53 over 80 that's
not the same right
well except wait a minute you remember
how I can simplify fractions look
clearly the top and the bottom I can
divide by 2 I can cancel out there is
also 2 as a factor here I divided by 2
the top and the bottom and bring little
fast over 80 Hey
so that was a fairy sir
that's a fairy song and so let me show
you how to pick a fairy song in this
piece of paper what you do is this every
time I take 3
secretive numbers here then the one in
the middle is the fire song of the two
on the side and what's amazing is that
when I change my number 234 here if I
take something else like for as if I
take two hundred then I'm losing this
number it will not be on my list anymore
however the next the one that is close
that's going to be this one probably I
will still have this property it's very
surprising to some extent unbelievable
and it took a while for mathematicians
to be able to devise a complete proof of
that result and the one who did that was
cautious one of the great mathematicians
of the 19th century when we find
something really surprising we want to
know is this a coincidence or is there a
deep fact behind that or at least this
is always true I'm going to do some
geometry and construct circles I'm going
to use the number line that I had here
but here is the following recipe which
I'm going to use whenever I see the
number P over Q again where P and Q have
no common divisors then I'm going to
draw the circle which is tangent to the
number line which is above the number
line and whose diameter is well I could
use any formula but my pinkie tells me I
should use one over Q squared let's do
it so one half at the bottom I have two
Q is equal to two something to 1 1 over
2 square and Emilee 1 over 4 so it sort
of looks roughly like this this is the
one thrown here 1/9 oh this one I don't
completely know but my king he just told
me that it
like this and then 1/4 my pinky is
better than my drawing skills and then
here by the way is one other one I had
to draw the circle of radius 1 over 1
square namely 1 it's this big circle
here and it under that is going to look
same with this one
yeah and then I can keep going but as
you I think I convinced you of one thing
which is that my drawing skills are not
very good but fortunately I have my
trusted computer so it's much smaller
than this this is the circle going at 0
over 1 radius will diameter 1 the one
going over 1 and 1 over 1 diameter 1 1 1
so these big circles are all above the
integers and then above the half
integers I'm going to get circle of
radius 1/4 and then above the multiples
on 1/3 I don't know if you can see 1/3 I
have a circle okay just 1/9 and then
it's beginning to be really hard to see
I can also use my computer and look here
there is 1/3 and 1/2 I'm zooming in 1/3
1/2 and then it's what you have in be
doing and you have that and then you
have more and then you could go I don't
know like this or how about here between
5 over 11 and 6 over 13 and it keeps
going ok tell you it it is funny but
with my funny rules like this all these
circles you see the way they are tangent
to each other they touch but they don't
overlap and so and there is no space in
between I think they do touch this is
called the fourth circle packing and
actually there is some geometry here
that you can show it when you have two
of these circles which touch each other
and then you have the number line here
there is a unique circle with touches
the number line and these two
sir Garcia okay that's a little bit of
the geometrical fact look look look look
at this so I was taking this 111 over 24
17 over 37 and the one that touches
these two circles and the number line
that oh my god that's 28 over 61 11 plus
17 that's 28 24 plus 37 that's 61 and
take care already turn it back it's
coming back so we have these 5a addition
everywhere in this picture again
this is true for any three circles that
touch each other like that in this whole
picture like this one here this pattern
is closely related to non-euclidean
geometry i cannot completely explain the
details but there is something deep
behind that the origin point so you can
deductively reason what happens here
okay Brady so this big circle is this
one and this circle is this one now what
happens to this circle here well again
we don't have to measure anything this
circle here touches the big circle and
touches this circle